do you know someone is ready to have
kids I think the wrong people are having
too many kids and the right people are
not having enough kids the wrong people
are Reckless when it comes kids they
don't think about it a lot they're like
hey government's going to pay me money
or hey you want to have unprotected said
oh I'm pregnant versus the right people
who overthink it guys like you like well
you know if we have a kid it's going to
cost us around
$280,000 between 0 to1 18 and if we want
to have three that's about a million and
if we're going to put them in our
private school probably more like
$600,000 so babe if we going to have
this at 12% interest you're overthinking
it pro right you know how many kids you
need to have you need to have five kids
I was about to say one or two I want to
see a guy like you have five kids
because if they're going to be like you
we need more use in the world but if you
have one kid you're screwing up the
ratios just looking at your energy
you're an incredible father for a girl
your girl's going to love you you're
going to be like her hero for the rest
of her life right I'd have 20 kids my
wife would be pregnant every year and
she'd have a 3-month vacation every year
of not being pregnant and then you got
your vacation babe you're done boom next
one here